the Dancing with the Stars cast was
finally revealed and the biggest
surprise by farm host Tom Bergeron's
reaction he is not happy at all he's
such a happy guy normally this is a
shocker Thomas calling out his own show
but the new pass was all smiles this
morning with he team's guest
correspondent Rachel Smith I literally
don't know how to dance
oh come on oh yeah I forgot that down so
I I know of four dances uptown girl
and my dancers from Chicago 65 year old
supermodel Christie Brinkley's an early
favorite she starred as Roxie Hart on
Broadway three times and has a strategy
if I can't do it with my feet I'll
distract him with my face from Christie
to Dawson cue the music
you planted a seed along that Oh like a
hundred percent did valentina and I are
gonna win Dancing with the Stars way
back when I was doing dump trust the B
in apartment 23 and I fixed the
storyline where the fake me went on the
fake Dancing with the Stars well within
minutes of this morning's casting
announcement there was backlash and
controversy in a surprise tweet post Tom
Bergeron seemed to suggest he was
against the casting a former
presidential press secretary Sean Spicer
Bergeron said he was hoping the show
would be quote a joyful respite from our
exhausting political climate and free of
inevitably divisive bookings from any
party affiliations and we look forward
to perhaps a podium being rolled out
onto the dance floor and maybe Melissa
McCarthy Chuck I think I think we've
that's probably past advice Tracey's
gonna explain it so you dumb babies
can't understand it and with Dancing's
ratings down expect format and voting
changes we needed to take a look at
things and maybe tweak things a bit but
casting follows a familiar formula
pro-athlete Lamar Odom is also a reality
star Chloe's ex and was in a coma almost
four years ago what is your strategy and
going into well just go hard
and put work into practice and bringing
the laughs the offices Kate Flannery if
nothing else we'll have a drink in lab
over this but it's dancing secret
ratings weapon really Hanabi this
bachelorette always speaks her mind Gigi
or just the plain Hannah I wish everyone
well for my season whatever they do but
this is about me and I'm gonna focus on
me dancing shedding the past to another
big show change to fan favorite pros are
out this season just go got one Oh God
lady these guys are my family
last year's winner Sharna posted today I
am unbelievably sad to not be back I was
just texting with Sharla recently she
she was surprised I was too Artem also
shared today how sad he is to be cut
former partner turned girlfriend Nikki
Bella took it a step further posting
their loss Artem will be on Nikki's
reality show total Bella's a lot more
next season both unfollowed dancing on
Instagram days before today's shocking
announcement you know any seats behind
that I don't but somebody else is called
I'm throwing everybody under the bus
really are you gonna give me some Finn
Tom a source tells DT Sharna and Artem
remained part of the Dancing with the
Stars family and it's not uncommon for
dancers to take a season off and then
come back one more change this is genius
we won't know the pairings until the
first night that'll make things
interesting
[Music]